ترند من فقره جديده في صباح العربيه نطل
عليكم فيها من بلد ما وبصحبه احد الزملاء
حدثنا عن ابرز ترندات الرائجه خلال الايام
الماضيه نفتتح الفقره اليوم من مصر مع ندى
حجازي وحديث حول ابرز حدثين اهمهما
الاهرامات على غلاف مجلات الامريكيه
صباح الخير يا نادين صباح الخير يا سهام
اول خبر معانا هو اختيار مجله تايم
الاهرامات لا تتصدر على غلاف المجله
الرئيسي تحت عنوان الجيزه وسقاره العوده
الى الاهرامات اعظم الاماكن في العالم
كمان نشرت مجله تايم تقرير عن اكثر
الوجهات اثاره في العالم والتي ينصح
بزيارتها خلال عام 2023
وابرزها الاهرامات بمنطقه الجيزه وسقاره
والتي وصفتها تايم بانها تمنحك تجربه
اكتشاف التاريخ بطريقه مختلفه واشرت ايضا
المجله لزياره المتحف المصري الكبير لما
يضم من قطعه اثريه تعرض لاول مره
وكنوز الملك توت عنخ امون ورؤيه تمثال
الملك رمسيس الذي يعد ايقونه المتحف ونصحت
بمطار اسفنكس الدولي حيث يقع على بعد 40
كم فقط من المتحف الكبير
عن الخبر التاني
شوي انه نوضح كمان للمشاهدين انه هاي
الفقره هي الاخبار البارزه من هذا البلد
ويخرج المراسلون مراسلون صباح العربيه من
الاماكن الحيويه والتاريخيه والاثريه
والمعالم في هذه البلدان طبعا بمصر
حدثتينا عن الاهرامات على غلاف مجله تايم
مجازين وايضا بدك تحسينا كمان عن قصه
الماذون يعني شو قصه الماذون هاي اللي
منتشر كثير على السوشيال ميديا
هو اترفض استئناف الماذون المزيف على حكم
حبسه سنه وكانت التهمه الموجهه له هي نشره
اخبار كاذبه على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
فيسبوك لانه كتب ان المقبلين على الزواج
هيحتاجوا ان هم يدفعوا رسوم بمبلغ ضخم جدا
عند عقد القران وده طبقا لقانون الاسره
الجديد وطبعا الشائعه دي ادت لان في كتير
جدا
اتمه زيجتهم قبل اوانها هروبا من دفع
الرسوم دي اللي هي اصلا مش حقيقيه
اتحكم عليه بالحبس سنه لانه هدد السلم
العام واضرب المصلحه العامه طبعا اكيد
احنا بدنا كمان الناس تكون مبسوطه ومرتاحه
ولكل كمان مقبلين على الزواج
شكرا جزيلا ندى حجازي من القاهره مراسله
صباح العربيه